time travel stories are often full of
crazy variables paradoxes and plot holes
which is especially true for the
terminator franchise
from the origins of skynet to the
endless cybernetic showdowns
this is the complicated terminator
franchise explained
come with us if you want to understand
in the world of the terminator
humans create advanced super computers
that eventually become self-aware enough
to realize that they're being threatened
when scientists realize this computer
network has become sentient
they attempt to shut their creation down
seeing humans as an existential threat
the ultra smart machines set about
systematically wiping them out
in 1997 the computers take control of
the united states nuclear arsenal and
use it to kill as much of the human
population as possible
the few surviving humans build an
underground resistance
hiding from weapons and robots built by
the intelligent sky in that computer
network
to hunt down and exterminate them this
resistance is led
by one man john connor in the year 2029
he leads the most successful attack on
the computer since their first strike
effectively shutting down skynet by
destroying their defense systems
in what was once colorado skynet
recognizes that conor
will be the biggest threat to its
continued existence post
2029 much in the same way that it
launched the missiles on what came to be
known as
judgment day back in 97 the computer
network makes moves to ensure its own
survival
it sends a killer cyborg back in time
with the mission to kill conor's mother
before jon can be born he'll find her
that's what he does that's all he does
the first film in the terminator series
begins with the 2029 versions
of john connor and skynet each sending
back representatives
using a time displacement device to
prevent their own respective extinctions
knowing that skynet has sent a
terminator specifically a muscle-bound
t-800
to kill his mother conor sends back one
of his own soldiers
kyle reese in a military action called
operation
chrono the two time travelers arrive in
los angeles in 1984 with nothing but the
skin or
organic matter on their backs the two
quickly set about acquiring clothes and
weapons
and needless to say the terminator
shopping methods are a bit more
murderous then in their search for jon's
mother sarah connor
the two hit upon the same idea consult
the local phone book
weapon in hand the t-800 begins
systematically slaughtering
every sarah connor in los angeles
fortunately the mother of mankind's
messiah is smart enough to realize
she's on a hit list while working as a
diner waitress
sarah sees news reports that women with
her name are being killed
and eventually winds up hiding in a
nightclub called technoir where she
calls the cops
but before the boys in blue can show up
both the t-800
and kyle reese stumble into the club
guns are blazing
rhys rescue sarah come with me if you
want to live
but as they try to escape the terminator
they run afoul of the police
ultimately getting themselves arrested
once the cops chased them down kyle
reese is grilled by both the police and
psychologists
who question his story about being a
time traveler from the future
sent to save the last hope of human
resistance against militant machines
unfortunately while rhys is being
detained the robotic serial killer
tracks sauer down to the police station
and after ramming his car through the
front desk proceeds to take out every
single police officer in the precinct
forced to go on the run again kyle and
sarah hide out in a hotel and at that
point
kyle shares that he's in love with sarah
in fact he's been obsessing over her
ever since jon first showed him her
picture
in the 2020s eventually they carve some
time out of the fight for their lives
and hook up
but the terminator has no time for love
and after killing sarah's mother and
impersonating her voice over the phone
he finds our heroes yet again leading to
a final fight
in the big showdown sarah and kyle
battled the t800 with pipe bombs
exposing his true cybernetic skeleton
eventually the trio wind up in a factory
where kyle dies from injuries sustained
in the fight
and sarah crushes the terminator to
death with a hydraulic press
even the tightest writing can avoid
hitting a few paradoxes when dealing
with time travel
but the terminator franchise stakes its
claim as the king of time travel movies
by steering into the skid the paradoxes
are baked into the films from the very
beginning
and the movies make no effort to hide it
in short the whole thing is built
upon the pre-destination paradox the
idea that someone could travel to the
past
and affect the future in a way that
necessitates them traveling to the past
in the first place
the entire terminator universe spawns
from this one impossibility as laid out
in the coda of the first film
the terminator ends with a pregnant
sarah connor driving through mexico
via audio tapes that she's recording for
her unborn son
john we learned that kyle reese is the
father when she stops for gas a child
snaps her photo and sells the polaroid
to her
and it's the very same one that john
connor gave to reese in the future
in short john knew that reese was his
father and sent him back in time so that
he could protect his mother
by sending him back john created the
circumstances of his birth
which would eventually lead to him
helming the resistance
however that fight against skynet would
lead to them sending back the terminator
and would produce the need to send rhys
back and save his mother's life
and so on and so forth for eternity
to be a fan of james cameron's time
traveling classic you have to try to not
think about it too hard
i'll be back the humans aren't the only
ones locked in an eternal loop
the spare parts of the terminator in the
factory after sarah connor's brush with
death
are soon found by researchers from
cyberdyne systems who are working on
advanced computers and robotics
in other words the building blocks of
skynet are created by unwitting
scientists using the technology left
behind
after skynet sent a killer robot from
the future to protect itself
as for sarah in between the first and
second film
she travels through latin america with
her young son
she befriends various guerilla fighters
and military men in order to train her
son to be a resistance fighter in the
future war against the machines
she explains this to jon before going
off to attack a factory
building the computer components that
will become skynet when she's arrested
she reveals that the future attack by
the machines is imminent
and naturally she's promptly locked away
in a mental institution
this leads a 10 year old john to believe
his mother is merely insane
although he uses the skills he was
taught to pull off minor scams and
crimes
under the noses of his foster parents
after its first failed attempt to snuff
out john connor skynet is ready for
round two
sending back another newer terminator to
1995 to kill the pre-teen john
adeljon knows this is going to happen as
he's already lived it
so he sends back a reprogrammed version
of the original terminator model to
protect his younger self
35 years from now you reprogrammed me to
be your protector here
in this time this is deep
terminator 2 judgment day largely
consists of the duel between this newer
shape-shifting terminator and the older
model after saving young john from being
run down by the liquid metal t-1000
the friendly t-800 helps break sarah
connor out of her mental institution
they come across sara in the midst of
her own escape helping her outrun both
the authorities and the robot sent back
to wipe the connor clan off the planet
sarah's first instinct is to head back
to mexico where she stocks up on
weaponry while hiding with some
sympathetic friends
when the t-800 reveals the name of a
computer scientist who's credited with
starting skynet
engineer miles bennett dyson sarah sets
off on her own to kill him
horrified that his mother would kill a
man in cold blood john connor gives
chase with the t-800
and they find sarah inside dyson's home
unable to kill dyson in front of his
family
instead the trio explained to the
scientist that his work will lead to the
end of the world as we know it
having seen the robot components of the
t-800 first hand
dyson believes their story and goes
along to help them destroy his research
with dyson's help our heroes break into
the cyberdyne labs and steal the
original terminator components
they set a bomb to destroy the entire
lab but they're interrupted by the
police
the cops shoot and kill dyson as the
terminator and his team escape
but the engineer is able to detonate the
bomb of course that doesn't mean the
t-1000 is going to slow down
and he keeps on chasing after his prey
after an epic chase with the new and
improved terminator
sarah john and the t-800 ultimately
square off against their enemy in a
foundry
however the older terminator is bested
by the next century's model
and the t-1000 impales the old protector
robot
and leaves him for dead after that the
t-1000 nearly traps and kills jon by
impersonating his mother
but the connors with the help of their
barely holding it together robobuddy
are able to knock the killer terminator
into a vat of molten steel
happy ending right well not quite
in one of the saddest final moments in
movie history
the t800 willingly dips into the boiling
vat
to destroy himself this way any parts of
him that might be used to build skynet
will be incinerated unfortunately the
good times are no match for times in
elasticity
the events of the future have to happen
for the past to play out the way it has
skynet will happen judgment day will
happen
all that matters is that john connor is
there to rally mankind
and fight the machines there are some
signs of hope
but you don't find them in terminator 3
rise of the machines
sure the initial date of judgement day
has come and gone without the world
turning to a cinder
but john connor is living as a hermit
hiding from machines in an off-the-grid
home after his mother's died of cancer
in fact john is steadily losing his mind
by waiting for judgement day
worse still skynet sends back a more
advanced terminator
hoping to kill key members of the human
resistance so they won't become a thorn
in
skynet's shiny metal side a tx
model terminator targets jon as well as
his future wife and of course
they're protected by yet another
reprogrammed terminator
however this friendly terminator comes
bearing bad news
but we stopped judgment day you only
postponed it
judgment day is inevitable he tells john
that the end of the world is coming
and he's been sent back into the past to
carry conor and his future partner kate
away from the blast after learning that
judgment day is on the way
john orders the terminator to take them
to kate's father a high-ranking air
force official
but the terminator refuses only obeying
when kate repeats the order
you have to save my father we can reach
cis
in approximately one hour the terminator
then reveals that in the future
he killed jon and was then captured
reprogrammed
and sent to the past on kate's orders
eventually our heroes try to stop the
military from working on the technology
that will become skynet but the
computers begin to take over the weapon
systems before jon and kate succeed
tragically kate's father is killed after
the tx activates the weapon systems in
his lab
but before he dies he reveals the
location of skynet's core
john and company then head towards
crystal peak colorado
in the hopes of destroying skynet as
they make their way to the location the
terminator repeatedly throws himself
between a pursuing tx
and the two would-be freedom fighters
but when they finally reach
crystal peak they realize it was all for
naught
kate's father wasn't telling them how to
destroy skynet he knew judgment day was
coming
and wanted them to survive in the end
skynet launches its attack on humanity
unleashing nukes and murdering billions
of people
john takes command of a radio in the
shelter and sets about becoming the
resistance leader he was destined to be
terminator the sarah connor chronicles
is the first major deviation we see from
the original trilogy
setting the tone for a decade of
alternate timelines and reimaginings
this 2008 series jettisons the event of
t3
and follows jon and sarah connor as they
attempt to hide from dueling antagonists
in the immediate wake of terminator 2
judgment day
as john and sarah are believed to be
responsible for the death of engineer
miles dyson
they live in fear of the fbi capturing
them
at the same time they're fully aware
that more terminators could be sent back
by skynet
to finish the job they failed in the
first two films
in fact one of those villainous robots
does eventually show up
at this point a protective terminator
named cameron appears at john's school
to ward off any attacks
and eventually our heroes learn they
must travel through time
from 1999 to 2007 if they want to stop
judgment day
what have you done you want to find
skynet
you want to stop sign it this is the way
the sarah connor chronicles is the first
terminator offering to deviate heavily
from the ideas of
pre-destination and causality loops when
sarah and john do
eventually travel through time in the
series they don't find older versions of
themselves
in the years between their origin and
their destination they didn't exist
when john connor closes the series by
jumping far in the future to stay alive
he finds that the war with the machines
is ongoing and the human resistance has
formed without him
the original terminator trilogy is grim
but it's a nearly perfect closed loop
everything had to happen because it's
already happened in the future
even if it all leads to the apocalypse
and a bleak future of
tooth and nail battles against
super-powered killing machines
it all had to happen to create jon
connor still
the idea of john connor's warriors was
too good for hollywood to pass up
and we return to the terminator universe
with terminator salvation
we are not machines and if we behave
like them then what is the point
in winning in this particular tale we
meet a warhead and john connor as he
leads an ultimately successful raid
against skynet
while the main point of the film is to
show guerilla soldiers pulling off
something cool against the big bad
machines
salvation does give us a glimpse of the
creation of the t-800 in fact
jon throws down against the hulking
monster during his attack on skynet
headquarters
and he nearly dies in the process as the
machines have intentionally guided him
to the base in hopes of finally killing
him
they're almost successful but an android
named marcus
who is initially upon in skynet schemes
sacrifices himself to keep john alive
the terminator timeline really goes off
the rails after salvation
courtesy of 2015's terminator genesis
with its bold departure from both
franchise chronology
and accepted english spellings this film
reboots the original series by playing
with the events of the very first film
in genesis kyle reese is still sent back
from the future by his commander john
connor
but when he shows up in 1984 he finds
it's been deeply altered from the 84
that fans all know
in this timeline sarah connor has been
raised from childhood
by a reprogrammed terminator
come with me if you want to live the old
terminator nickname
pops has protected sarah from attacks by
terminators after her parents were
killed by an even earlier terminator
sarah and pops have built a time machine
and sarah wants to travel to the
original era of judgement day to stop
skynet
kyle however convinces them to head to
2017
to avert a disaster he saw in visions
from his childhood
the movie jumps through causality hoops
with the terminator version of john
traveling to 2017
in an attempt to stop their plot to
destroy skynet or
a genesis the terminator john was
created after skynet fused the real john
with machine matter
and they used him to ensure skynet's
survival throughout time
while the trio of kyle pops and sarah
are successful in their attack on the
genesis system
a post-credits scene reveals that the
core of genesis
was unaffected setting the stage for
more sequels that never happened
given how jumbled the timeline was the
team behind terminator dark fate
decided to jettison the baggage of any
movie not made by james cameron
their answer to the franchise's gordian
knot of timelines
was to chop the parts they didn't need
and to keep things moving
however rather than having jon lead the
resistance
dark fate posited that jon was killed by
yet another terminator
while living with his mother in latin
america in the year 1998.
the movie focuses on sarah's attempts to
protect the new human savior
danny ramos together sarah and a cyborg
super soldier named grace
protect danny from an advanced
terminator called rev9
on top of all that the trio finds
themselves on a sci-fi side quest
see sarah knew about dany because an
unknown source was sending her messages
detailing the mission of each terminator
sent into the past
hoping to find the source of the
messages the heroes set out on their
journey
all while keeping dany alive through
constant attacks from rev9
oh and just to make things even more
complicated skynet doesn't exist in
grace's future but
an analog called legion is following the
same path
legion an ai built for cyber warfare
when the heroes track down the message's
origin point
sarah is shocked to find the same t-800
that killed her son
as it turns out he was stranded in the
past when his alteration of time led to
skynet no longer existing
without a mission or superiors he worked
to assimilate into human society
and ultimately came to feel guilt over
his actions against humanity
those aforementioned messages were his
way to clean his conscience
eventually our band of misfits hatch a
plan to destroy rev9
but it falls apart catastrophically in
their final confrontation
grace is killed in the fight and the
guilt-ridden t800 drags the rev9 into an
exploding machine
destroying both robots dark fate ends
with danny and sarah
watching a young grace play on a
playground hoping to avoid the situation
that led to her death
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one